our Kourtney Kardashian and Scott Disick
making things work there's things that
you just should know I don't know
because you don't discuss with me or
communicate Scott proposed a question
for his ex and the mother of his three
kids on Sunday's episode of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians when do you think
we're gonna get married by the way like
40 you think that when I turn 40 I'm
gonna go hey I've been looking for this
drunk guy and it has a bunch of dirty
stain fanfare you two are so nuts that
marriage conversation started after the
two exes argued over Scott not being
invited to Khloe's surprise birthday
party 38 year old Kourtney had a weak
excuse on why he didn't make the guest
list I didn't want to have you coming to
the birthday and be photographed going
in and just like photographs going in is
your concern and I didn't want to say
like I just didn't want you there so if
I can't say anything nice I just won't
say anything at all that's all bull it's
funny to realize how fake you really are
though
[Music]